with the bizarre sitcom setting and
plenty of reality bending antics
one division is said to be one of the
weirdest mcu stories so far
so it makes sense that marvel fans have
come up with their craziest fan theories
ever
here are some of the wildest fan
theories about wonder vision
during the events of avengers end game
the team managed to reverse the effect
of thanos's cataclysmic snap
restoring to life the half of the
universe had wiped out after gathering
together the six
infinity stones however one notable
exception was vision
who was killed prior to the snap and so
was not among the heroes who returned
for the final battle
and although wonder certainly got some
well-deserved payback against thanos for
killing vision
it's obvious that she still misses him
deeply one popular theory that's made
the rounds among fans
is that a grieving wonder will use her
chaos magic to access
the multiverse inserting herself into
realities where vision is still alive
one redditer for example theorizes that
wonder will attempt to replace the
alternate version of herself
in each dimension but her presence will
always have ramifications on each
timeline
they wrote she plays out the same events
hoping that this is a universe where she
envisioned can be together
each episode we would see the same
series of events but set in a different
universe
and though the circumstances may change
it always ends in disaster
in this sense each new style of sitcom
that wander and vision inhabits
would represent a whole new reality i
see nothing of this
you have absolutely no reason to be
you were saying if that is the case
wonder basically tearing her way through
the multiverse
is bound to have some truly devastating
consequences
one division's trailers feature plenty
of potential hints and easter eggs for
eagle-eyed marvel fans perhaps the most
significant of them all however
are the brief shots of wander and
visions young children fans of the
comics know that these children will
most likely grow
up to become wiccan and speed these
young heroes who also go by billy kaplan
and tommy shepard
are core members of the young avengers a
super team consisting of second
generation superheroes
such as cassie lang and kate bishop
billy is gifted with a magical skill set
similar to his mother's whereas tommy is
a super speedster like his uncle
quicksilver some fans believe that these
characters are going to have a larger
role in the future of the mcu
this rings especially true when you
consider that cassie lang has already
been introduced
kate bishop is set to debut in 2021's
hawkeye series
and a number of other disney plus shows
are set to follow a younger roster of
characters
could one division mark the beginning of
a new generation of marvel heroes
so here's a question how exactly is
vision back among the living in one
division
this is a question that the show is
bound to answer at some point or another
given that it appears to be the central
crux of the whole story
some fans believe that it's wonder who
has found a way to bring her lover back
to life
either by utilizing her chaos magic or
by traversing the multiverse but what if
someone else has had a hand in vision's
resurrection
while the mcu's version of vision is
obviously closely linked to wonder
there is one other character with whom
he shares an even greater bond
ultron his creator in 2015's avengers
age of ultron
ultron's nefarious plan hinges around
his attempt to create the vision
in his image although tony stark and the
avengers managed to thwart those efforts
vision and ultron are still deeply
linked in both the mcu and the comics
perhaps one division would draw some
inspiration from 2001's
ultron imperative arc wherein the
avengers discover that ultron's
creations contain a secret programming
directive
to rebuild him fans have been
speculating for years that ultron will
return to the mcu
could it now finally be happening in the
marvel universe being a superhero means
resigning yourself to an existence
filled with sacrifice and tragedy
even in that context though few mcu
heroes have lost more than wonder
maximoff
her parents were killed by tony stark's
bombs her brother was killed fighting
ultron
her country was destroyed her lover was
taken from her
and then she herself even died albeit
temporarily
in thanos's snap and all that trauma is
bound to take its toll on wonders mental
state
following a highly popular internet
theory murphy's multiverse theorizes
that a good portion of one division
will take place within wonder's own mind
due to her inability to recognize what's
real and what's not
perhaps this is why the show will
utilize different sitcom filters
to display wanda's changing perceptions
and why vision still seemingly has the
mind stone in his head the real question
about this theory is what happens when
wonder gets out
in the comics the scarlet witch has
occasionally become unstable
which given her off the charts power
levels can be a major problem for
earth's mightiest heroes
should one division follow in those
footsteps there's a chance that the
events of the show
could result in wonder becoming a
genuine threat to humankind
scarlet witch first debuted in the mcu
alongside her brother pietro maximoff
aka quicksilver
played by aaron taylor johnson perhaps
fittingly pietro exited the mcu
almost as quickly as he came ultimately
sacrificing himself to save hawkeye
during the events of avengers age of
ultron
you didn't see that coming
[Music]
of course as any marvel fan will tell
you death isn't
always permanent when it comes to the
world of superheroes keeping that in
mind
it's certainly not out of the realm of
possibility that quicksilver could find
his way back into the mcu
and if it were to happen it only makes
sense that wonder would be the one
behind his return
but what if the pietro she resurrects
isn't the pietro she intended to bring
back
in june 2020 murphy's multiverse
reported that evan peters who played
quicksilver in three of fox's x-men
films
had landed a significant role in one
division this casting set the internet
ablaze with predictions that peters
would bridge the gap
between the mcu and fox's x-men
franchise
perhaps wonder finally realising the
full extent of her powers
finds a way to peruse the multiverse in
search of her brother
and inadvertently plucks a different
pietro from another reality
it'd be a strange move indeed but
considering a number of future mcu
movies are set to do something very
similar
it might just be likelier than you think
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany are the
only mcu veterans returning for one
division
it's also been confirmed that both
randall parks jimmy wu
and kat denning's darty lewis will pop
up in the show
although it remains to be seen just how
important they'll be
if you're a gambler you'd be wise to bet
your money on the idea that wu and lewis
are both now working with sword
the planetary defense organization that
helps protect the earth
some fans believe that sword shows up in
west view after wonders alternate
reality takes over
perhaps resulting in a dimensional dome
that appears to form over the town but
what if sword is the first team on the
scene because they were the ones who
caused the rift in the first place
it's no secret that wonder has become
one of the most powerful beings on the
avengers roster
but she's also garnered an unfortunate
reputation in the process
given her history wanda might be
considered a threat to society by the
government
maybe sword has found a way to keep
wander trapped in a reality warped
prison
and this is where one division really
takes place
in the comics wonder has something of a
checkered past while she has undoubtedly
experienced her fair share of arabic
moments
she is perhaps most known for her
failures and one in particular
the destruction of 986 thousand six
hundred and eighteen mutants
in the marvel universe in the lead up to
2005's house of m
storyline the scarlet witch's powers
became dangerously erratic
resulting in her killing her fellow
heroes like hawkeye ant-man
and even vision after the avengers and
x-men come together to try and get her
back under control
wonder first creates a reality wherein
mutants are the dominant species
and then reverses it by simply muttering
no more mutants
although many mutants eventually find
ways to regain their powers
wonder is permanently excommunicated by
the x-men
and mutant kind for what she'd done in a
blink and you miss it shot in one
division's trailer
you can make out a wine bottle
displaying the label mazon de mapre
which is french for house of misery
or if shortened house of m this image
set the internet to light with theories
that one division
could possibly draw inspiration from the
house of m storyline
since there are no mutants currently in
the mcu however one popular theory
suggests that wonder will actually be
responsible
for creating mutants in the universe
perhaps even by saying
no more mutants it's amazing the
difference a coma can make don't you
think
in 2019's captain marvel akira akbar
played the young monika rambo
the spunky daughter of carol danvers old
wing woman maria rambo
it sounds like young moniker is now all
grown up and looking to make waves in
the mcu
this time portrayed by tiana paris how
she fits into one division story however
still remains to be seen
monica rambo actually has a very
significant history in marvel comics so
her mtu presence isn't something fans
will take lightly
she was the first female to take on the
mantle of captain marvel
and the first african-american woman to
officially join the avengers
soon becoming one of the strongest
heroes in the entire marvel universe
having been confirmed to appear in the
upcoming captain marvel sequel
it seems likely that paris's rambo will
be around for a while
but how exactly will she get her powers
one division's trailer contains a
glimpse of monika being knocked
backwards through what appears to be
some form of dimensional portal
some fans are speculating that rambo
could perhaps be working for nick fury
or sword in order to help contain wonder
in an alternate reality
once wonder catches on she knocks monica
back into the real world
inadvertently granting her energy
manipulating superpowers in the process
auntie agnes is here and i've got a
couple of tricks up my sleeve
uh let's just take it from the top
one thing that all of one division's
trailers have emphasized is that
katherine hans character agnes
is going to play a significant role in
the series but who exactly is she
playing
many fans have suggested that agnes is
actually agatha harkness
who in the comics is an experienced
witch who helps mentor wonder
in the ways of true magic while harkness
has mainly served as a mystical ally to
earth's defenders on the page
some fans are theorizing that one
division will flip the script on the old
witch's morals
as one reddit supposit perhaps agatha is
actually the one responsible for keeping
wonder in her false reality
they write but even more so with that
part in the trailer where the sword
agents ask wonder who is doing this to
you leads directly to agnes laughing
wickedly
why would she be doing this well perhaps
she's serving a great power one who
might benefit from wonder losing her
mind
one popular fan theory about one
division involves nightmare the fear
lord of marvel's terrifying
nightmare dimension nightmare is such a
force to be reckoned with because he can
capture sleeping people's astral forms
and torment them in his realm
which he has done to several heroes in
various comic sacks
in late 2019 murphy's multiverse
reported a rumor
that nightmare had been cast and would
be the main villain of one division
this would be an especially interesting
twist because it would likely tie into
the upcoming
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which will also reportedly
feature wonder in a starring role
in 2016 doctor strange director scott
derrickson
told igm what he'd like to see in a
sequel for marvel's sorcerer's supreme
he said
i really like the character of nightmare
and the concept that the nightmare realm
is a dimension
i think that's in the introductory
episode of doctor strange and they
always loved that
obviously derek's son is no longer
attached to direct and the multiverse of
madness but the villain may well remain
the same
perhaps nightmare is responsible for
holding wonder in her dreamlike reality
if so it would set the stage for a heck
of a cameo in the show's final episodes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]